[Musique]
et
bonjour et bienvenue dans dimanche en
politique pour la couronne d'angleterre
les choses sont simples les successions
se règle en famille tout est prévu et
ordonné c'est pas pareil en politique
notamment à droite chez les républicains
où il ya eu des héritages difficile et
en décembre un nouveau président ou
nouvelle présidente sera élu à la tête
des élèves avec comme objectif de
redevenir les premiers opposants à
emmanuel macron notre invité aujourd'hui
est la présidente des républicains annie
genevard bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sur ce plateau je vous laisse vous
installez vous êtes député du doubs et
vous êtes à la tête du parti en
attendant que les adhérences décide en
décembre prochain de choisir votre
successeur à moins que vous ne soyez
dans la course vous nous direz ça tout à
l'heure elizabeth 2 évidemment on en
parle depuis quelques jours décédé à
l'âge de 96 ans vous aussi un vous
n'avez connu qu'elle a sur le trône
d'angleterre puisqu'elle a réuni pendant
70 ans qu'est ce qui a représenté pour
vous
d'abord une femme d'exception une
souveraine respecter quelqu'un qui a
garanti le ciment de la nation et puis
sans doute ce que j'admirais le plus
chez elle et ce à quoi les français
aussi était très sensible c'est qu'elle
a toujours fait passer le service de la
nation avant tout ça ça de vie c'était
duty faust ce dossier avant les devoirs
d'abord et soit après et je crois que
c'est ce qu'ils attendent de leurs
dirigeants alors justement regardez
cette phrase elle a donné à sa nation et
leadership ferme du courage de la joie
et quand il le fallait de l'espoir c'est
emmanuel macron qui a écrit ça sur le
registre de condoléances à l'ambassade
de france à paris qui aujourd'hui rempli
ce rôle en france ben je pense que c'est
sans doute ce que emmanuel macron
aimerait incarner peut-être y at-il la
définition en creux de ce qu'il voudrait
être aux yeux des français et je pense
que quand on peut dire cela d'un d'un
dirigeant c'est une vraie reconnaissance
il ya un mot que je retiens c'est celui
d'espoir je crois que dans la période
difficile que nous traversons le le rôle
des responsables politiques c'est bien
sûr d'affronter les difficultés courage
mais d'avoir de la clairvoyance et de
pouvoir redonner de l'espoir aux
emmanuel macron dit par exemple nous
sommes en guerre il est clairvoyant mais
il ne donne pas forcément d'espoir
écouter ils n'ont ils ne donnent pas
d'espoir d'autant que le mot de guerre
il l'a abondamment utilisé depuis deux
ans pour le coc gide à propos du conflit
russo ukrainien
oui bien sûr nous vivons les
conséquences de la guerre mais nous ne
sommes pas en guerre il devrait être
plus comment dire plus optimistes ils
devraient donner plus d'espoir je pense
que pour donner de l'espoir aux français
faut prendre des bonnes décisions et il
faut être attentif aux résultats des
décisions que l'on prend je pense que la
crise politique que nous vivons
aujourd'hui qui se manifeste par une
abstention grandissante c'est d'abord
une crise de résultats souhaitez vous
qu'il ya un hommage particulier soient
rendus à l'arène lorsque les députés
reprendront leurs travaux début octobre
à l'assemblée nationale moi je
trouverais ça bien digne à la mesure de
cette personnalité absolument hors norme
de cette longévité exceptionnelle battu
tout de même par là la durée du règne de
louis xiv qui a été de 72 en mai et puis
cette femme qui dont chacun souligner
l'intelligence
l'humour
la constance même si elle était interdit
de s'exprimer sur des sujets politiques
elle a joué un rôle politique
fondamentale donc ça justifierait tout à
fait qu'on grands dommages aux lèvres
d'état qu'elle était à l'assemblée
nationale à l'assemblée nationale
sobriété consommer moins d'énergie c'est
désormais la nouvelle consignes répétées
par emmanuel macron et le gouvernement
pour faire face à l'augmentation du prix
du gaz et d'électricité mais les
français eux voit les prix augmenter
partout
consommer français et économiser
l'énergie c'est la double injonction du
gouvernement avant un automne plus
frileux on regarde bien les prix avant
d'acheter chose qu'on faisait pas avant
la salade qui étaient à leur travail ma
team devient aujourd'hui c'est quand
même stade la luz nous sommes en guerre
c'est un état de fait nous devons
l'énergie fait partie des instruments de
guerre utilisée par la russie se fermer
et quand la russie ferment le robinet de
gaz une trentaine de piscine sous
concessions privées ferment leur bassin
sans prévenir
lundi des abonnés sont débités de leur
abonnement du mois de septembre et lundi
soir la piscine ferme donc honnêtement
comment ne pas être scandalisé beaucoup
de l'énergie sur l'année les 15 millions
la cie ont continué comme on était parti
pour l'année 2020 ne saurait qu'ils sont
mignons c'est dommage puisqu'on peut
être aller chercher des économies
ailleurs ont-ils les enfants et les
parents loisirs mais les économies
suffiront-elles comment faire face à des
hausses exorbitantes pour les
collectivités c'est ça qui nous inquiète
s'il pouvait pas payer parce qu'il ya
des services publics qui vont à terme et
à des écoles des centres aérés contre il
bloque il va être obligé de remettre la
main à la poche le patron des
communistes lui est sa solution d aide
du gouvernement contre la menace de ne
pas payer les factures
ce n'est pas de la désobéissance
comme certains me l'ont attribuée c'est
une résistance républicaine
si toutes les oppositions des signes
europe à cet appel elles se sont en
revanche retrouver pour boycotter le
conseil national de la ''refondation''
voulue par le président macron quand on
n'est pas là faux pas après expliqué qu'
on n'a pas été consultée ou que c'est
trop vertical outre ceci outre cela et
formule de bon sens qui dit que les
absents ont toujours tort ça vaut pour
aujourd'hui aussi
annie genevard des piscines fermé à
cause des dépenses de chauffage qui
deviennent trop lourdes c'est on en est
là en france vous avez vu fabien roussel
à la fête de l'humanité le numéro un du
parti communiste qui dit aux élus ne
payez pas vos factures on n'a plus les
moyens de payer et on va pas non plus
payé advitam eternam comme ça vous le
rejoignez là dessus non je ne le rejoint
pas parce que je pense que ça mettrait
en difficulté tout le système et ça
n'aurait pas de ça n'aurait pas d'avenir
une attitude de insurrectionnelle
non je crois que bon on vit là les
conséquences de deux phénomènes d'abord
effectivement le conflit ukrainien
mais aussi la conséquence en matière de
politique énergétique
conduite par emmanuel macron drones
symbole et la fermeture de fessenheim il
faut des aides aux collectivités locales
pour passer le cap par exemple je dis ça
parce que les républicains vous avez
beaucoup d'élus locaux qui vont être
confrontés à ces factures et bien sûr
mais tout le monde est confronté à cela
les entreprises qui voient leur facture
d'électricité les contrats négociés
qu'edf fois disent jamais en péril un
nombre incalculable d'entreprise les
particuliers tous les français
évidemment l'appel à la sobriété
énergétique
croyez vous que les français est attendu
que le président de la république leur
dise d'être moins consommateurs pour
être vigilants sur leur propre
consommation ils sont bien obligés les
collectivités locales donc on est tous
impacté par une crise énergétique qui
résulte pour une bonne part d'une
politique aberrante qui a mis en péril
ce qui était le lin le fleuron de
l'énergie française la souveraineté
énergétique française quel est le
nucléaire la filière nucléaire ça c'est
absolument dramatique et vous savez que
dans la loi aujourd'hui la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
il ya encore l'objectif de fermer 12
réacteurs donc c'est complètement à
contre-courant si je peux dire de ce
qu'il faudrait faire cet été le
gouvernement a fait voter la loi pouvoir
d'achat avec les voix des députés les
républicains dont vous êtes ça comprend
notamment arabes et qu'on a actuellement
de 30 centimes payés par l'état sur
l'essence total a rajouté vincent tibia
que total qui fait ça donc on en est pas
à anne euros 50 le litre comme vous le
souhaitiez vous n'avez pas l'impression
de vous êtes fait avoir non on
s'approche on s'approche on s'approche
d'un heureux 50 on est passé d'une
politique de chèque à une politique de
baisse du prix du carburant pour tout le
monde c'est à dire pour les classes
moyennes qui sont toujours les grandes
oubliées vous savez c c'est notre texte
que nous avons approuvé en partie
puisque nous avons la vraie
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires nous avons la
monétisation des rtt nous avons l'aide
pour les chaudières à fuel nous avons
effectivement la baisse du prix du
carburant le confier pour ce jour pas le
compte y est en tout cas il y est bien
davantage que le texte initial qui nous
était proposé et puis ça n'augure pas de
l'avenir alors justement parce que pour
le budget 2023 bruno le maire lui veut
prolonger le bouclier tarifaire sur le
gaz et l'électricité qui a permis de
limiter cette année 2022 à 4%
l'augmentation du prix du gaz
d'électricité pour les particuliers
voulez-vous un prolongement vous
le gouvernement y est presque obligé
parce que sinon ça va mettre des
millions de français dans la plus grande
difficulté que vous viendrez l'autre
alors et mais ça ne suffit pas ça ne
suffira pas la politique de chèques elle
se fait quand même au prix de la dette
et sur le dos des générations futures ça
veut dire qu'il faut une autre politique
énergétique il faut relancer sans tarder
la filière nucléaire songez que
aujourd'hui on a fermé des centrales
nucléaires est réouvert des centrales à
charbon on va racheter à prix d'or
l'électricité allemande qui est fournie
par les centrales à charbon et on va
vendre notre gaz à l'allemagne alors que
nous sommes quasiment ou deux suffisant
le bouclier tarifaire pour 2023 c'est
inévitable d'accord c'est inévitable et
est par exemple aussi le même ministre
de l'économie bruno le maire dit qu'il
ne ferme pas la porte à l'élargissement
du chèque énergie que reçoivent chaque
année 6 millions de français et il dit
on pourrait revoir les critères de
revenus pour qu'il y ait plus de
français qui reçoivent ce chèque énergie
là aussi vous êtes pour le gouvernement
entend enfin qu' il faut prendre en
compte les classes moyennes qui sont
toujours les grands oubliés des
politiques publiques et de ce point de
vue là je pense que c'est utile de
raisonner effectivement en intégrant les
classes moyennes mais vous savez pour
nous la droite qui sommes des libéraux
ce qui n'exclut en rien la solidarité
nous ce que nous voulons c'est que le
travail paye le travail paye davantage
et donc ils vont augmenter les salaires
donc il faut effectivement travailler de
façon à augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
français je rappelle que le pouvoir
d'achat des français a baissé au premier
trimestre de cette année de 2% c'est la
plus forte baisse des pays européens
donc ça oblige à s'interroger sur notre
modèle économique
mais les vélos que des augmentations de
salaires pour vous c'est à l'ordre du
jour ou pas et bien est-ce qu'on va
monter des salaires pour que pour que le
même assez naturellement les salaires
vont augmenter dans un contexte de
raréfaction de la main d'oeuvre les
entreprises pour attirer la main
d'oeuvre et pour la conserver augmente
les salaires c'est pas bien mais c'est
très bien et salaires sont trop faibles
en france on le sait bien mais faut ça
passe par quoi par des augmentations de
salaire mais comme ça qu'ils doivent
être payées par les entreprises parce
que la droite en général c'est plutôt
par des baisses de cotisations sociales
en général alors il faut effectivement
ce que tu as baisser baisser le coût du
travail évidemment le taux de
prélèvement et est trop important en
france on a un différentiel de presque 7
points avec les pays de céder l'état
français est toujours plus vorace si on
diminue pas les dépenses publiques pour
pouvoir précisément alléger la facture
et augmenter le travail le fruit du
travail des français on n'y arrivera pas
ça veut dire aussi qu'on peut trouver
peut-être de l'argent ailleurs il ya un
grand débat en ce moment sur la taxe
éventuels sur les super profits des
grands groupes y êtes-vous favorable
chez les républicains parce qu'on
connait pas trop votre position là
dessus alors de façon générale
les républicains ne ne partage pas le
réflexe français qui est de dire un
problème une taxe mais là une difficulté
à anapu mais là non je crois que la taxe
sur social total a accepté de baisser le
prix du carburant c'est allé directement
dans la poche des français si on avait
instauré une taxe sur les profits de
total en imaginant qu'on puisse
puisqu'une partie des profits sont
réalisés
à l'extérieur de l'hexagone ça allait
dans les poches de l'état dont on sait
que c'est un monstre vorace tandis que
là c'est aller dans la poche des
français ce qui est bien préférable donc
une contribution pour moi est préférable
à l'impôt pathak sur les grands groupes
ni sur les super profits pour voir
emmanuel macron essaie de se sortir de
cette difficulté politique puisque vous
avez noté que son ministre des finances
est contré sa première ministre n'est
pas des problèmes il y avait plus tôt
pour donkey prix il préconise de
substituer à un sujet français une
réponse européenne une taxe européenne
donc mais vous savez on s'en prend
finalement toujours même puisque au bout
de la chaîne il ya le contribuable
national pour vous très clairement pas
de taxe sur les super profits je
considère qu'il faut d'abord ça implique
de définir ce qu'est un super profits
ensuite il ya en france qu'on appelle
l'impôt sur les sociétés qui tienne
compte du résultat des sociétés ça
existe alors que l'impôt sur les
sociétés soit modifié en fonction de
rélever réévaluer ce qui est clair c'est
au tour de piste de travail enfin je ne
sais pas on verra mais en tout cas ce
que je note c'est que c'est un sujet qui
est très portée par la france est
soumise qui conduit une mission
parlementaire sur ce sujet
par principe on n'est pas trop non plus
dans la roue de la france a soumis les
ouailles et donc alors parti libéral
comme le nôtre ne vient à l'impôt est la
taxe qu'en dernière extrémité dernière
petite chose parce que leurs devis et et
ça va être le vote ou pas du budget 2023
les républicains vous avez dit on le
votera pas mais vous voterez contre où
vous obtiendrez alors ça on verra pas ce
que vous savez pour voir le texte
le texte on ne connaît pas pour
l'instant ce n'est pas déterminée et
il compte ou abstention s'est pas
déterminés en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que quand on est dans la
majorité on vote le budget si on est
dans l'opposition et complète le budget
on n'est plus dans le plus de niro six
avions pu s'abstenir effectivement c'est
probablement le choix qu'on aura à
arbitrer mais sur des questions aussi
fondamentales que celle de l'énergie
convient d'évoquer bloquer le prix du
mégawattheure pour que les français
arrivent à se chauffer s'éclairer cette
année pour que les entreprises
continuent de fonctionner ce seront par
exemple des indicateurs forts la relance
de la filière électrique est candidate à
présent salaire dit tout de suite moi je
voterai contre 1 weeds août et
je pense qu'il ya de fortes probabilités
pour que le vote soit content mais
l'honnêteté intellectuelle veut que je
vous dise on va déjà illuminé l'amant
déterminant dans trois mois les
militants les républicains vont choisir
leur nouveau président ou nouvelle
présidente ils sont actuellement on peut
dire 3 plus ou moins officiellement sur
les rangs la campagne est lancée et vous
retrouver en position d'arbitré
longtemps la droite a eu le goût du chef
et l'habitude du pouvoir mais rien
depuis dix ans et pourtant il faut mener
la barque jusqu'au prochain congrès pas
facile
mes amis si on s'attaque
si en coulisses les entourages
s'amuse à balancer des méchancetés il
faut que le débat ait soit sain sinon et
on est perdu et je vous dit la patronne
des républicains de la compétition pas
la bagarre moi je suis la gardienne de
la maison et aussi je vais me poser en
garant de l'unité c'est un parties
abîmées qui a failli disparaître à la
suite du résultat de la présidentielle
cruel aussi pour la candidate nous
n'avons pas atteint les 5 % j'ai besoin
de votre aide d'urgence on peut
reprocher à sarkozy de ne pas avoir
évolué je le soutenir peut-être est-ce
toujours voté à droite et je continuerai
à voter pareil ici et vous avez voté
classement ben ammar kron p l'avenir
selon vous pour la droite
cependant je suis sans voix là
aujourd'hui je suis sans voix militants
déboussolés députés qui s'accrochent à
leurs circonscriptions aux législatives
la droite résiste mieux en juillet le
groupe ait l'air réduit de moitié votre
quand même la première loi pouvoir
d'achat avec le gouvernement l'assemblée
nationale
des candidats déclarés d'autres à venir
mais pour quelle opposition et quelle
ligne projet notre famille politique à
une condition c'est de tout changer et
pas seulement le mot élèves toujours
adhéré à ses convictions d'une droite
forte qui s'assume j'adhérais ouvert à
16 ans je veux demain aussi que notre
formation politique retrouve un peu
l'esprit du hertha cinq ans à tenir pour
se trouver un avenir avec des jeunes aux
idées neuves sujets qui préoccupent les
jeunes en fait l'écologie à l'égalité
femmes hommes et c'est des sujets dont
la droite peine à saisir c'est l'une des
clés pour eux on montre aux français
qu'on est pas bloqué en pour m'apprendre
le pen alors ni jeune baron vient de
vous voir mettre en garde les candidats
à la présence des républicains contre
des dérapages possibles il y en a eu
dans le passé on s'en souvient ça veut
dire que vous ne faites pas confiance à
eric ciotti bruno retailleau aurélien
pradié ça veut dire que une élection
interne c'est toujours une période
périlleuse et que alors que nous sortons
quand même objectivement affaibli de la
l'échec de la présidentielle il faut
qu'on soit très prudent c'est une
compétition donc dans toute compétition
cherche à se différencier
mais il faut que ça se fasse dans un
esprit absolument que tu leur demander
précisément alors précisément je leur
demande de bien sûr faire valoir leur
candidature mais en respectant leurs
compétiteurs voilà tout simplement alors
que vous pourriez être arbitre parce que
pour vous êtes candidate ou pas à vous
alors je vous en viendrez arbitres comme
ça en vidéo regardez la photo oui tant
elle fait tout à fait mais que vous êtes
candidate à la présence dont je ne suis
pas candidate à la présidence de l air
parce que précisément dans la fonction
d'arbitré que qui est la mienne dans
dans cette période où j'occupe la
fonction de présidente et dans cette
période d'élections internes eh bien je
pense que ça ajouterait de la confusion
et j'ai décidé de ne pas candidater
c'est un renoncement un peu parce que
vous y pensiez il ya quelques semaines
encore non c'est pas un renoncement
parce que renoncer ça veut dire avoir
déclaré qu on y allait et finalement
revenir sur cette hypothèse et vous y
avez réfléchi j'y réfléchis bien sûr en
tant que responsable de mon mouvement
que vous êtes actuellement que je suis
favori sur la cogestion actuellement
mais donc j'ai considéré vous savez ça
voulait dire sortir de la présidence
renoncer à la présidence que j'exerce
renoncer à ce rôle d'arbitré apaisant
puisque c'est aussi ma fonction dans la
clarté de mes convictions parce que moi
je suis une femme de droite qui n'a
jamais varié dans mes convictions donc
je serai là demain auprès du futur
président pour pour aider à la
reconstruction de notre famille peut
être autant que la drôle service des
français d'autant que la droite va
devoir retrouver sa place il ya quelques
mois encore vous étiez vice présidente
de l'assemblée nationale c'est à dire
que vous présidiez là où perchoir
certains débats importants aujourd'hui
il n'ya plus de république et en bureau
de l'assemblée nationale en revanche il
ya deux vice-présidents et règles par
exemple ça vous gêne je trouve que c'est
profondément gênant et que la majorité
n'a pas joué le jeu d'une représentation
conforme au poids politique des uns et
des autres s'arrêtant à une gestion
comptable de la question donc je le
regrette profondément mais enfin c'est
tous les ans qu'il est élu le bureau est
ce que vous demandez donc à y aller le
brunch iv de revoir je pense que cette
question devra être revue en effet parce
que il n'est pas pensable que nous
grande famille gaulliste qui sommes à
l'origine de notre constitution
de la vème république nous soyons
absents d'une fonction au cynisme en
politique
passer de la responsabilité des uns et
des autres surtout la présidente de la
présidente a son mot à dire
naturellement d'autant que je crois
n'avoir jamais démérité dans cette
fonction on va accueillir maintenant
clair chakravarty chef du service
société politique cazaux conversation
france pour sa première cape blanche
[Musique]
bonjour cléa bonjour consiste bonjour je
viens des valeurs de droite parce qu'on
peut organiser la droite c'est quoi quel
numéro un mais y at il des valeurs de
droite l'a effectivement vous avez pas
mis entre autres choses affirmé le
retour des parties vous avez également
flatter les valeurs de votre parti à
l'est républicain et vous avaient
proclamé une soi-disant droitisation de
la france notion qui quelque peu
contestables notamment celle chez les
chercheurs moi j'ai plutôt envie de vous
parler la droitisation de la droite pour
comprendre un peu où on en est et
jusqu'où on peut aller donc annie
genevard j'aimerais d'abord savoir
qu'ils sont vos électeurs aujourd'hui et
surtout où se trouve-t-il
alors je crois que une des difficultés
dans laquelle nous sommes c
c'est une question de l'incarnation
parce qu'en réalité moi je le crois
profondément la france est à droite
d'ailleurs les enquêtes d'opinion
tendent à le démontrer assez clairement
de quoi les français sont ils en
attendent ils sont en attente de
retrouver une sorte de fierté nationale
nous avons perdu des pentes in nos
souverainetés souveraineté alimentaire
souveraineté budgétaire souveraineté
énergétique la france certains mêmes
parlent de déclassement donc retrouvé
une fierté nationale une fierté
française une question se pose aussi
pour beaucoup de français la question de
l'autorité du respect de l'ordre public
on voit bien avec la multiplication des
faits divers tous plus violents les uns
que les autres que la france connaît un
problème majeur la question de la
solidarité libéralisme économique est
solide à réaliser je vous parlais tout à
l'heure de solidarité vous parliez qui
avait évoqué dans meego l'isthme votre
parti est le parti du également du rpr
de l'ump bien sûr il y avait une
certaine fibre sociale insulaire
d'ailleurs un chez la droite en france
or aujourd'hui on se peut se demander où
aller on a entendu dans les sujets on
parle de retraite de solidarité
d'égalité homme-femme d'écologie bien
sûr autant de sujets dont votre parti ne
s'empare pas et au contraire on entend
les mots autorités libertés identités
travaille à mon sens les valeurs de la
république
vous parlez c'est liberté égalité
fraternité a donc noté dans quel dans
quelle mesure on se retrouve dans ces
valeurs que dont vous que vous êtes bien
sûr bien sûr mais vous savez moi j'ai
été maire avant d'être députés et les
maires sont des jeux d'hier et des
agents de fraternité du quotidien et
beaucoup de mères elles sont et l'air
vous le savez et on agit en permanence
au service de nos concitoyens je crois
que dans la droite dans la droite
libérale il y a une dimension de
solidarité mais une solidarité bien
comprise qui n'est pas de l'assistance
ou de l'assistanat mais qui est de
pouvoir de pouvoir et bien prendre en
compte les difficultés de nos
compatriotes mais d'essayer de les en
faire sortir et ne pas les gilles
maintenir comment ça se traduit
concrètement qu'est ce qu'il reste de
propre à l air finalement parce qu'on a
quand même le sentiment que vous avez
des cadres de l air qui sont partis
soient justement chez une extrême droite
en jeu quand marine le pen et exim ont
bien sûr mais aussi une grande vous
parlez de votre électorat une grande
partie est d'aller voter pour mâcon oui
tout à fait parce que parce que emmanuel
macron habile son discours d'un vernis
de droite mais à présent de la
république est un parti majoritaire qui
prélèvent davantage qui ne résout pas la
question de la sécurité plus d'impôts
plus d'insécurité
plus d'immigration plus de dette ce
n'est pas une politique de toi alors on
va parler de sujets de société concrets
que les ajustements oui merci beaucoup
effectivement vous l'aviez dit tout à
l'heure
être une femme en politique où la vie
dit dans plusieurs cultures presse n'est
pas évident moi je vais vous poser la
question assez directement est ce que
vous considérez comme féministe annie
genevard bah écoutez moi je pense que
toute ma carrière politique
l'éducation que j'ai reçue d'une mère
qui était très engagé pour amener ses
filles à l'indépendance me porte du côté
d'un féminisme qui n'est pas un
féminisme excluant qui exclut une
exclusion pour ma féminisme exclu en c1
féministes qui se construit contre les
hommes mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup à
conquérir encore du côté des droits des
femmes égalité salariale reconnaissance
et puis dans la police justement l'âge
des femmes alors justement avec les
femmes et pour les femmes qu'est-ce que
vous êtes qu'est ce que vous proposez
concrètement pour lutter par exemple
contre les violences conjugales alors je
vous rappelle que notre famille
politique a porté une loi au parlement
sur pour lutter contre les violences
famille et contre les violences contre
les femmes avec le bracelet anti
rapprochement c'est le secrétaire
général de notre mouvement garcia n'y a
quand même pas mal mais on en est passé
par la loi quant à l'application de la
loi ça c'est de la responsabilité du
gouvernement
si ça fonctionne pas c'est de la
responsabilité sur le sujet par exemple
alors par exemple l'inscription de
l'avortement dans la constitution qui
devrait être à nouveau débattue
prochainement comment ce que vous
pensiez vous positionner dessus alors
écoutez on n'a pas encore arbitré le
sujet au sein de notre formation
politique c'est pas évident alors moi
personnellement je n'y suis pas
favorable parce que je pense que la
constitutionnalisation du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
n'est pas nécessaire nous nous ne sommes
pas les états unis qui remettent en
cause ce droit ce droit n'a jamais été
remis en cause en france et je pense que
ceux qui l'ont porté ce qu'ils ont
portés ont voulu faire un coup politique
en laissant à penser que dans notre pays
se doit a été remis en cause on l'avait
fait le même procès à françois fillon
c'est injustifié d'un toute dernière
question réellement toute dernière pièce
oui
très bien vous les mânes uniquement veut
rouvrir le débat sur le droit de mourir
dans la dignité faut-il revoir la loi
pour aller plus loin dans
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie je
pense que c'est un sujet extrêmement
sensible
du reste il fut un temps où emmanuel
macron disait que c'était si sensible
qu'il ne voulait pas qu'on la borne dont
vous voyez il ya un revirement tactique
de position il faut l'aborder si on
laborde faut l'aborder en étant vraiment
respectueux d'une procédure de la
consultation comme le sont toutes les
lois de qui interroge les tic l'éthique
à la française donc on a on a inscrit
pas dans la loi
l'euthanasie ou le
droit de mourir sans d'infinies
précautions parce que ça touche à des
questions qui sont plaisants rouvrir le
débat quand elle râle et d'y ouvrir le
débat il sera réouvert je pense par la
majorité
qui l'a annoncé donc merci clés à mercy
qui les a une dernière question le sait
peut-être une affaire gaël perdriau
c'est le maire les républicains
saint-etienne c'est une des
personnalités de feu de votre parti il
fait l'objet d'une information
judiciaire parce qu'il aurait piégé l'un
de ses adjoints dans une mise en scène
sexuelle enregistré en vidéo si les
faits sont avérés gaël perdriau
pourrait-il rester chez les républicains
alors d'abord il n'a plus de fonction
exécutive au sein de notre moulin or
j'ai dit c'était hilal s'est rapproché
d'un génial c'est pourquoi que voilà il
est toujours adhérent cette affaire est
grave elle est entre les mains de la
justice qui se prononcera et le moment
venu s'il était convaincu de culpabilité
évidemment que ça
ça interrogerait son maintien au sein de
notre famille politique a dit joe dever
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans
dimanche en politique réalisé par
tristan do la rédaction en chef pierre
sébastien à retrouver sur le site où
l'application france info est tout de
suite sophie le saint pour l'actualité
de la mi journée
[Musique]